I want to tell you a story about Munson
Munson was this twenty eight-year-old
interior designer a father to a loving
daughter and a son who found himself
behind bars due to a broken-down
judicial system he was framed for a
murder he didn't commit
and he was sentenced to the gallows
there are two victims to these matters
the victim worked early died in the
matter and Munson who had been sentenced
to prison for her face which she did not
commit he was locked up in a Cell 8 May
7 with 13 other grown up men for 23 and
a half hours a day food was not
guaranteed that you'd get and I remember
yesterday as I walked into their room
are where I was I imagine the kind of
cell that Munson could have been living
in because they told it that they wrote
the small rooms that were there was
slightly bigger than the 8 by 7 cell but
being in that cell as they awaited the
executioner because in prison he did not
have a name Manson was known by a number
he was just a statistic he did not know
how long you'd wait the way it could
have been a minute
the executioner could have come the next
minute the next day which could have
taken 30 years the weight had no end and
in the midst of the excruciating pain
the mental torture the many unanswered
questions that Manson faced he knew he
was not great to play the victim he
refused to play the role of the victim
he was angry at the justice system that
had put him behind bars but he knew the
only way he could change that justice
system or help other people get justice
was not to play the victim change came
to Manson when he decided to embrace for
give miss for those what put him in
prison I speak that with a fact as a
fact because I know who Manson is
I am Manson my real names are Peter
Munson OCO and after my conviction after
that awakening of forgiveness I had this
move to help change the system I already
decided also great to be a victim
anymore but how was I going to help
change a system that was bringing in
younger inmates every day who deserve to
be their families
so he started mobilizing my colleagues
in prison my fellow inmates to read
letters and memoranda to the justice
system to the Judicial Service
Commission there are numerous task
forces that have been set up in our
country Kenya to help change the
Constitution and we decided to grasp at
those to clash at those truths if I may
use that word if only to make the
justice system work and what for all
just about the same time I met a young
university graduate from the UK called
Alexander McClean Alexander come in with
three or four V's colleagues from
university in the agafia and they wanted
to help assist set up a library in
committee maximum prison which if you
google you'll sees written as one of the
fifteen was prison in the world that was
then but when Alexander came in he was a
young 20 year old boy and I was on death
row at that time and we took him under
our wings we just it wasn't it was an
honest trust issue he trusted us even
though he on death row and through that
trust we saw him and his colleagues from
the University refurbished the library
with the latest technology and set up
our the infirmary to a very good
standard so that those who was falling
sick in prison would not necessarily
have to die in indignity having met
Alexander I had a chance and given me
the he gave me the opportunity and the
support to enroll for University
at the University of London just like
Mandela study from South Africa I had a
chance to study at committed
maximum-security prison
and three years later I became the first
graduate of the program from the
University of London from within within
the prison system having graduated what
happened next
having graduated now I felt empowered i
was not agreed to play the helpless
victim but I felt empowered not only to
assist myself to prosecute my own case
but also to assist the other lawyer the
other inmates who are suffering the
stimulating justices that I've just been
spoken about here so I started writing
for them legal briefs with my other
colleagues in prison we did them much
you could that wasn't enough Alexander
McLean and his team at the African
prisons project decided to support more
inmates and as I'm speaking to you today
there are 63 inmates and staff in the
Kenyan Prison Service studying law at
the University of London through
distance learning
these are changemakers who are being
motivated not only to assist the most
indolent in society but also to help the
image and others get access to justice
down there in my prison cell something
kept stirring me the words of Martin
Luther King kept hitting me and was
always telling me that peep if you can't
fly you can run and if you can't run you
can walk but if you can't walk then you
can crawl but whatever it is whatever it
takes just keep on moving and so I had
this urge to keep moving I still have
this urge to keep moving in whatever I
do because I feel the only way we can
change our society the only way we can
change the justice system which has
really improved in our country is to
help get the systems right so on 26th
October last year after 18 years in
prison I walked out of prison on
presidential pattern I'm now focused on
helping a PP the African prisons project
achieve its mandate of training and
setting up the first law school and
legal College behind bars where we're
going to Train
where we are going to train inmates and
stuff not only to assist the fellow
inmates but to assist the entire wider
society of put the poor who kind of not
access legal justice so as I speak
before you today I stand here in the
full knowledge that we can all redeem in
ourselves we can all reexamine our
situations we can always examine our
circumstances and not play the victim
narrative the victim narrative will not
take us anywhere I was behind bars yeah
but I never felt and I was not a
prisoner the basic thing I got to learn
all that if I thought and if you think
you can you will but if you sit thinking
that you can't you want it's as simple
as that
and so I'm encouraged by the peaceful
revolutionaries I've had on this stage
the world needs you now the world needs
you today and as I finish my talk I just
like to ask each and every single one of
you here wonderful vehicles changemakers
innovators the wonderful global citizens
we have a Ted just remember the words of
Martin Luther King let them continue
ringing in your heart and in your life
whatever it is wherever you are whatever
texts keep on moving thank you
[Applause]
[Music]